في تصريح اخر اذا قال رئيس مجلس دوما
الاتحاد الروسي فيجيسلاف فولودين ندعم
نظام كييف من قبل الولايات المتحده
واوروبا ادى الى انشاء دوله ارهابيه في
وسط اوروبا مشيرا الى انه لا مفاوضات مع
الارهابيين بل لابد من تصفيتهم وكتب في
قناته على التليجرام ان مقتل مدون عسكري
في انفجار في مقهى يوم الاحد الماضي دليل
على انشاء دوله ارهابيه وسط اوروبا بفضل
دعم واشنطن وبروكسيل
لسلطاتك رفقه تعبيرها
قال رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات الروسيه ان
الوضع في اوكرانيا اكتسب سمات حرب دينيه
حيث لا توجد لدى الغرب خطوط حمراء حسب
قوله اضاف المسؤول الروسي ان الغرب فشل في
فرض عزله عالميه على روسيا وفق تعبيره
البولندي قال رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات
الروسيه
تنتظر اللحظه المناسبه للسيطره على اراضي
في اوكرانيا وعن جورجيا قال المسؤول
الروسي ان الغرب يحاول اقناع تبليسي بان
الوقت مناسب الان لاستعاده ابقازيها
الجنوبيه وخوض صراع عسكري مع روسيا